we were all wondering when Donald Trump
was going to weigh in on Nike endorsing
Colin Kaepernick with the most recent ad
that we covered yesterday that just do
it ad where I believe they said
something on the lines that sacrifice
you know you have to sacrifice
everything said I don't remember it
maybe it wasn't a good ad but I digress
the point is Nike stood by Colin
Kaepernick since 2011 all the way
through and they gave him a sweetheart
deal that includes endorsements
advertisements sneakers t-shirts and
jerseys I don't know if a jerseys are
included but you get the picture and we
were wondering we knew Donald Trump
could not hold it in for long
he tweets the following out this morning
he said this quote just like the NFL
whose ratings have gone way down Nike is
getting absolutely killed with anger and
boycotts I wonder if they had any idea
that it would be this way as far as the
NFL is concerned I just find it hard to
watch and always will until they stand
for the flag okay no not really the
protests and the burning of their their
apparel you know the the I guess logic
is not a part complete component of our
requisite of being a Republican because
for you to burn their apparel and their
shoes that means you've already bought
it which means they already have your
money you're just burning your money you
might as well take money out of your
pocket and just set it on fire that's
how smart you guys are and in terms of
intensity the the conservatives have
tried to boycott everything I mean and
just go down the list of things they
tried to boycott and nobody has has been
affected at all Nike absolutely took it
into consideration whether or not this
investment into Colin Kaepernick was
going to pay off some dividends right
and to be sure what they did was not a
social you know statement as much as it
was a business decision I don't don't
look at Nike as some moral institution
because they're not right they still
have sweatshops across the globe but the
point is is that they decided to use
some of those sweatshop profits and to
stand behind Colin Kaepernick giving him
a job essentially I
Kapernick would have been out of work
altogether out of money all together had
it not been for Nike and Kaepernick has
been funneling his money through
charities that invest in social
movements and advocacy and so it's in a
way it's like capitalism paying for its
own demise but anyway that's neither
here nor there the point is Donald Trump
is trying to make this be so it's not
the case that the backlash is so much so
that they're getting killed by anger and
boycotts there's no way for him to
actually know that besides that not
really being the point he's trying to
speak this into existence sort of so to
speak he's trying to encourage his
supporters to go out there and be angry
at Nike and to boycott Nike and and you
know all this is going to do is just
encourage the other side to purchase
more conservatives don't have that
mobilizing capacity in terms of
righteous indignation to shut down a
movement they don't they the best that I
think that conservatives can do is D
platform both sides have demonstrated
their ability to get someone T
platformed but they haven't shown the
ability to to actually end a company
based on their boycotts because they're
not accustomed to this type of protest
you have to understand they represent
power not only in terms of who's
occupying the White House the Senate the
Congress and the majority on the
conservative on the Supreme Court this
that is one form of power that they
represent but conservatives also
represent institutional power over the
years that's what they want to conserve
they don't want to progress to a
different generation to a different era
in American politics because they have
been the beneficiaries of the current
power structure and so why would people
who are the beneficiaries of the current
power structure have to understand how
to mobilize and organize and to conduct
boycotts they don't because who are they
boycotting right that's like that's like
someone on the I you know I was gonna
give a really bad example of a
plantation but I'm gonna stop
mid-sentence so I don't have to you know
apologize to David but the point is this
Nike is doing just fine
I don't personally care whether they're
doing fine or not outside of the context
of their support for colin kaepernick
specifically because colin kaepernick
has demonstrated that he is going to
support social movements even though it
might be some of his last dollars he has
invested millions of dollars into local
activists who were out on the streets
making a change one last thing on this
before we go to a break the the the
whole deal about the NFL and and
kneeling for the flag as I've covered in
great detail on many times this has
absolutely nothing to do with respecting
the flag if I want you to remember it if
not go to my go to my page the Benjamin
Dixon show calm and catch one of the
videos where I covered that Colin
Kaepernick was taking a knee two weeks
before anyone said anything they had
pictures of them they made comments
about it but no one actually had any
problem with it they were just curious
as to why it wasn't until they found out
why he was protesting that they started
to lose their mind conservatives in
particular
oh he's protesting police violence well
this is this is disrespectful right
that's number one they did not have a
problem with Colin Kaepernick until they
found out why he was protesting number
two he actually got the idea of kneeling
during the anthem from someone in the
military right our former Marine or
something along those lines so it you
know the idea that it's disrespectful to
the flag is is absolutely ridiculous but
then it's even more ridiculous to
suggest that it's disrespectful to the
troops number one because he got the
idea from a former troop and number two
because it has nothing to do with the
troops the flag isn't the representation
of our troops even though through in
this over nationalism that they're
trying to push onto us they want to make
the flag synonymous with the troops but
it's not the case and actually we're not
talking about the flag or the troops
we're actually talking about kneeling
during the national anthem which itself
is a problematic document yes because of
its reference towards slavery in the
third stanza just wanted to put that out
there but the point is is that they have
no they had no problem with this protest
until they found out why he was
protesting
if they found out he was protesting
something that they agree with then they
would be championing him right now today
no questions asked anyone who says
otherwise is a liar that's number one
number number number two I don't even
know what number I am I'm own at this
point but last but not least how about
that last but not least you have to
understand people in power will never
approve of any type of protest so
they're gonna make you chase the wild
goose it's a wild goose chase because
they're always gonna say oh you should
protest like this but as soon as you
protest like that then they're gonna say
oh no that's disrespect but you have to
protest like this that's because your
protest fundamentally challenge their
power structure and so they will never
approve of your way of protesting
because your protests are a threat to
entrench the power so all of this all of
this is one big presentation of them
protecting their power this is all one
big game to them to say oh you have to
do it this way and as soon as you do it
that way they're gonna find a new way to
criticize what you're protesting
ultimately people in power whether it is
literal power in the White House the
Congress the Senate the Supreme Court
and locally whatever or if it's in
structural institutional power
beneficiaries of this power structure
like conservatives are they will never
agree with any means of protest because
what you're protesting fundamentally
threatens their power structure